e aí
a escola fábrica fábrica escola
16 horas isso eu tô com sono viu eu me
acordo meu pai se acorda banho escovar
os dentes colocar o uniforme eu e meu
pai trânsito asfalto semáforos tudo de
um cinza idêntico nunca notei a
diversidade tão sem vida que existem na
cidade
é só deferimos o lugar e vou para escola
fábrica e meu pai para fabricar escola
mas no fim é tudo igual eu entro na
escola meu pai bate ponto na fábrica e
vou para o meu assento meu pai para sua
máquina os professores falam as máquinas
rugem lápis papéis óleo engrenagens é
tudo igual
e os funcionários não sorrir em querem
seu salário os professores estão
exaustos querem seus salários para
gastar quatro mesmas coisas mês após mês
os alunos não pensam repetem não criam
reproduz o que lhe é passado as
mercadorias
e não pensa não falo são modeladas
e os professores falam ensina o que nós
vamos aprender apenas fingir saber
o número de letras em cores nos
computadores e nos livros nas famílias e
nos cadernos é tudo igual
a música o quadro ciências os cadernos
se escrevem as planilhas se preenchem os
gráficos estão cheios
e é tudo igual
e o gerente passa os funcionários
sorrirem
e satisfeitos em fingir satisfação e
manter sua dignidade dinheiro
e as mercadorias são registradas acende
efeitos passam adiante as demais retorno
à criatividade é tamanha que não mudaram
nem o nome série de produção
e os alunos também têm seus números e
séries são lista de chamada são números
é tudo igual
os sinos tocam não são das igrejas hora
da refeição
a fila no refeitório hora do intervalo
celulares em mão eu estou online e de
conectar do mundo meu pai está online e
desconectado do mundo
as sirenes tocam hora de voltar é tudo
igual
e acabou guardar materiais
a pressa para finalizar mais um dia sem
pensar que o próximo será igual carros
buzinas motos placas o gigante massa
inerte de pessoas apresentadas
já chegou em casa online desconectado na
rede meu pai na televisão minha mãe
prepara a janta anúncios propagandas nos
movem para mais um dia de estudos para
ter um futuro um futuro de compras é
tudo igual
e a noite desce com a noite anterior
amanhã tem aula vai dormir é tudo igual
e eu vou para escola fábrica meu pai
para fabricar escola a única diferença
entre a fábrica ea escola é um ambiente
húmido quente e mal iluminado da
primeira talvez a fábrica não seja assim
para que os alunos sobrevivam até chegar
na fábrica
e aí
e essa foi a minha crônica finalista da
olimpíada da olimpíada de língua
portuguesa e 2019
e o que é escola reserva para mim o
futuro
e o que é escola estava para os seus
filhos no futuro
tá bom
nós sabemos que a nossa duas escolas
elas não se entendem mais no passado do
que nos prepara para um futuro
e o pior se quer pizza compreender o
nosso presente
ou será que alguém de fato pensa no
nossa série de futuro é com estudantes
em primeiro plano é válido destacar a
forte desvalorização da criatividade e
da autonomia
e é notado isso quando observamos o
início desse sistema às origens desse
sistema lá no século 18 revolução
industrial
nós podemos perceber a forte comparação
com o sistema de produção fabril
e ao escrever minha crônica passa em
minha mente as lembranças da infância
quando meu pai me levava para a
indústria onde trabalha
ah e por ser criança e observava tudo
bom e quando escreve hayley irônica e
perguntaram tem que série você é
o e logo me veio a lembrança uma frase
muito utilizada na indústria a série de
produção está atrasada
o e logo lembrei da comparação que já
havia feito da escola e da fábrica e
pensei por que não fazer uma crônica
sobre
e como próprio historiador peter burke
falou um povo que não conhece sua
história está condenado a repetir e
exatamente isso que acontece nos atuais
sistemas de ensino
e eles nos ensinam a criar apenas
repetiu que nos é passada
bom e como podemos solucionar essa
situação
nós podemos começar com a formação
pedagógica do professor formando
profissionais que saibam ouvir o
estudante e assim montar o seu método de
aprendizagem próprio
nós vemos um pouco disso na tutoria
presente no meu colégio e nas demais
escolas de tempo integral
e onde o professor ele observa a
formação do aluno ajudando em sua vida
escolar e sua vida pessoal porque não
fazer isso nas demais escolas
nós precisamos adquirir um método de
avaliação informativo no qual não se
vale o estudante por meio de um papel e
sim por meio da sua formação ao longo do
ano
é isso assim desperte sua criatividade e
autonomia
tô fazendo eles independentes da
construção do centro próprio futuro
muito obrigada
e aí